olá pessoal de quem fala em mudar que
sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo mostrado aqui uma
novidade que com certeza vocês já leram
pelo título estão à espera de ver o novo
amigo do bode mas essa novidade é um
pouco triste pela maneira como as coisas
aconteceram mexe eu acho que devo tudo
em bem porque agora nós temos um novo
membro aqui é dar colando em que o ine
não sei se vai ser novo membro da
colômbia mas já vou contar o que se
passou é desde já pensou se vocês forem
novos aqui no canal em inscrevam se
deixem muito laquê neste vídeo é sério
isso ajuda muito que o canal eu estou a
tentar falar mais alto do custo porque
está muito bem aqui fora então eu vou
tentar falar mais alto do que o vento
espero que não se importa mais para lá o
que interessa pessoal eu vou me
apresentar aqui o novo companheiro novo
amigo do bode e vamos lá vamos à procura
deu e ainda não sei como é que te chamar
e portanto não tem nome e atenção porque
o novo animal que eu tenho aqui é muito
fofo portanto vocês vão ter um ataque do
furacão já esquentando com este vídeo
então preparem-se pessoal preparem se
porque eu fui mas cirurgia mas apesar
desse animal foi muito fofo também está
muito bravo tempo pra correr aqui por
todo o lado e é muito difícil apanhar
porque é novo e ainda não conheço então
para eu conseguir esse animal um
mortífero eu vou te chamar o bode
primeiro é porque tem andado agora
sempre atrás de bolle néca boy do brasil
só vou procurar meu favor boni onde está
o born e aqui está online
quem é mori é de bodinho etapa será zé é
que está o nosso amigo bob o pequenino
já não é mais
já não é mais mole mas vamos correr
ainda correspondem à memória
só não quero mais três já não já não tem
mais não pode ter qualquer efeito que as
mães não mais fiéis e moreira último
vocês podem ver pelo pelo deu eu estava
irritado
ela está com fome ele quer mais como
linha e não vai comer uma lei do senado
que vai orientar o novo amigo é preciso
que um dia já localização deu mole
quando é que está não é primeiro no
camboja diesel só quer saber de carro
pelo amigo ronaldo tornou amigo ai ai ai
está bravo traz me pode ajudar a
encontrar a localização no domingo onde
está bob
eu sei que o sabendo que está disponível
não como
a câmera pode desmaiou neckel está a
vodka e aos gramados
eu só quero um brasil muito mimada disse
botín podium de cansar conta disso desde
um blog onde é que o teu amigo está é o
bode é o board irmãos só como podem
perceber bola e não está a ajudar a
encontrar o amigo deu então vamos à
procura ó como é que eu vou chamá-lo o
bari 2 em 1992 faz tentar a volta à casa
já o pessoal eu avistei nossa escritura
aqui está ela o amigo da oab é que está
ele não está a correr como heróis na
cabana em 2 calma tudo bem tudo vai
embora e ainda não se habituou em mim e
eu fui muito ainda vou de calma calma
com a câmera não fui só eu preciso
começar a apanhar um filme desde que eu
vim aqui pra casa está comigo no gelo em
todo o resto bola e não comeu está
comendo a bola de dois não fuja da loja
em pistas ainda tentava fugir
aí que está a fugir não precisa fingir
não pode isso nos faz mori
pode isso não faço não faz acaba não se
podem ver eu ainda está meio perdido mas
já está habituado a que a da colômbia
que é que se passa é que se passa bem
está ajustado acomodar isso com calma
muita calma em isso não faz mal podem
ver o pessoal tem muito medo de mim
ainda mas já está mais calmo bode dois
vêm cá quer mostrar às mães crítico e
dois está com muito medo tomar uma coisa
que eu também para quê ela adora comer
estas árvores então anda sempre aqui
perto e neste momento está a fugir pra
que juntamente com gór e obra de
pequenino mode pequenino não precisa ter
medo e lindo bebê pode ficar quieto não
fica com ciúme
vamos tentar outra folha é que tem
pequenino e isso já não tem medo não tem
medo muito é muito fofo pessoal diga lá
é muito fofo
olha isso eu acho que alguém quer mais
folhas né e agora vou tentar a arrancada
que várias folhas porque como vocês
viram já comeram esta parte toda do
baixo então eu vou tentar acompanhar
algumas porque ele vai estar com o foco
agora é
já está na hora do lanche olhou a bola e
já as perdas foi a mais quente do que
demande eu achei fome hora do lanche
agora é a vez de bob verbeeck pede bebê
como podem ver eu estava desconfiado
pessoal eu peguei as folhas de festa
sempre e eu também dei para o estado por
causa da câmara na época uma coisa
giganta frente deu mas está tudo bem
pode bem olha tirar que cuida te olha se
a é muito fofo eu acho que alguém quer
mais folhas por causa de roubo as folhas
do bob bennett body fala o que tem aqui
um bicho que isto é só uma planta vem
cabo a e b toma forma mais próxima de
mim eu estaria me esperando em um
estúdio onde pode não isto talvez por
isso o que tem que ser rápidos com bolas
roubadas folha só de ver como rápido de
que o dia de amanhã
isso isso isso pe será que eu venho não
metálicos como rápido pinto tem que ser
rápida de benê irmãos só como vocês
acabaram de ver nós temos um novo
cabrita que na colômbia e como é que
isto aconteceu eu vou explicar por que
vocês já podem pensar da arquitetura da
taxa não fica brito não tacto compraste
que brito não dark inscrito estava
abandonado e parcialmente sim eu vou
explicar bem o pessoal vamos explicar
então que aconteceu num dia destes há
uma semana atrás delas foi há uma semana
o senhor vai bater na minha porta e com
um ar bem preocupado e obra e claro só
perceber o que se passava e quando eu
parar eu era o segurança aqui do
condomínio uma das pessoas que estão
aqui e volto ao condomínio está tudo bem
então eu abri a porta e ver o que se
passava e os seguranças um pouco
preocupado isso o mec a tua cara tá lá
fora' assunto vão já correr atrás dela
eu ai meu deus me cobra fugiu atingido
casa não pode ser eu nunca fugi de casa
tem alguma coisa estranha nisso está
aqui sim mas eu fui atrás de uma mesma
porque se eu fosse muito longe já não
conseguia apanhar e como vocês viram
agora falei muito rápido foi
precisamente com esta velocidade que eu
fui atrás do gob é porque eu pensei que
era mesmo eu e bom eu fui com segurança
enfim dentro do carro dele e fomos até
um lado aqui do condomínio é bem mais
longe meu eu pensei logo um único código
2d distância toda y el tiempo mococa
assim tanto ou então corre mas ele
encontrar comida pelo caminho e acho que
não ia tão longe assim e aí já achei
suspeito mas eu fui eu continue atrás do
blog chega uma altura em que os
seguranças e dj estamos perto e eu
estamos perto como assim mal chega com o
carro parou o carro e houve uma quebra
mesmo
o herói bollier esta quebra mas por que
não um bebê eo vira olha que tato cabra
eo rumo assim esta não é nem quebra a
minha casa branca é maior é macho apesar
de ser mas também muito mas isso não
interessa eu pensei que fosse uma cobra
na altura ainda por cima é bem é muito
mais pequeno do que o meu blog eu fiquei
logo aí o que eu fui fazer o cinto casa
à pressa eu fui muito burro nem confirma
esfriar muito boa estava em casa e
realmente eu estava aqui comer bem bem
preparado que atua
mas de qualquer forma com essa
preocupação toda a equipe que sair
rápido muito rápido e foi à procura do
bode no entanto não era o meu voto é boa
mas quando cheguei ao local esta casa
estava no meio da estrada sem dono
completamente perdida e também mas a
gente já volta a tentar apanhá la e sem
saber o que fazer
lewis é que a ibm havaianas em que o fla
com chinelo e tudo foi muito rápido casa
nem deu tempo ao sábio tirei avaiano eu
não sei que revelou estrada e consegui
apanhar esta quebra foi muito difícil
porque ela fato muito mais do que bob
com muito mais rápido é porque quanto
mais pequenos são mais excluir até então
elas conseguem salvar tudo inclusive só
nesta semana esta quebra já saltou duas
vezes de casa e foi quando eu finalmente
consegui apanhar aqui brinca eu não
sabia o que ia fazer ela estava perdida
estava numa estrada polícia e da
trovoada e ninguém conseguiu falar pra
casa então eu pensei 'ok vamos falar pra
casa eu vou deixar aqui tive que nadar
colando e dois dias e vamos ver isso
tudo me parece que o que aconteceu
perguntam vocês não apresentou nenhum e
ninguém vai à procura dela e entretanto
já se pôs uma semana e ninguém vai
receber da cabra tipo não por seu dono
ainda ninguém sabe quem é quem do
condomínio então é complicado
a única coisa que eu consegui fazer o
que pude fazer é ficar com a cabeça aqui
até por ser o dono no entanto não
aparece então eu acho que oficialmente
esta quebra vai ser um novo morador aqui
na casa porque eu não vou soltar outra
vez eu pelo menos na minha lógica tempo
se ela tivesse mesmo um dono que se
preocupar se com ela o dono já tinha 26
o que se passava eu já tinha dito na
portaria que desapareceu a cabra que
aumentam muito muito confuso porque não
sei o que fazer mas tecnicamente um novo
animal aqui de lá com mandioca e não
oficial mas é pelo menos até por ser o
dono e apesar da quebra estar muitas
cabra não é um cabrito
apesar do câmbio está muito estável está
a correr bem está bem alimentado está
tudo ótimo mas eu acho que em breve eu
tenho que ir ao plenário com ela porque
tipo eu acho que não tem vacina ainda
quer então eu vou ter que fazer isso em
breve porque eu tenho uma grande
esperança para utilização já nem sei
como fiz em outra curiosidade pessoal é
que eu acho que não são da mesma raça
o meu blog eu acho que é uma cabra né e
este poder que um não sei o quê mas eu
acho que é bem diferente eu acho que
isso pode e vai ficar muito grande
ou então encontrar um novo ataque vai
ficar grande isso vai continuar assim eu
não aceito muito confuso já outra coisa
que aconteceu pessoal é que entretanto
nesta semana que eu tive que acaba por
ser um falso dono dela então eu pensei
mesmo segmento envolver acaba mas quando
estava mesmo a fazê lo perceber que não
era bem o dono então acabou por ficar
aqui mas se o dono desta casa tiver a
ver este vídeo por favor venha buscar
locais mas só estudar amor e atenção
acaba profissão ela fica que a mesma é
mas eu tenho quase certeza que se vierem
não buscarei a época da chuva é pra
comer mas não e eu acho que vai
acontecer nos pés mas mesmo assim espera
o dono aqui buscá lá eu vou devolvê-lo é
claro mas com provas evidentes que esta
cabeça do dono é porque não vou devolver
a quebra e atuou ontem que terá prova
que esta quebra é mesmo um tipo deu o ok
e agora quer perguntar a opinião vocês
acham que o de ficar com a cabra como em
essex e oeste não esse comentarem sim
pessoal como tem também um nome que
queiram que eu dê é esta quebra e por
falar em nomes e estavas elemento é
pensar chamado de mas não sei se é
um bom nome portanto comentem se acham
que o pode ser um certo é porque é
muito parecido ao ambiente esse pessoal
eu sei que o é um ou sei lá
o antigo personal que aquilo
isso é uma cabra eu sair mas gabriel não
me dói me e eu sei que tu está costume o
sul estão a comer juntos quero que vocês
vão fazer e estou a gostar né vida é bom
é sempre a comer e vinha gostosas é moda
bebê e não fugi bebê não fuja e não
quero fazer mal cama eu buscava foi
acreditar eu já vou só deus também
adoram essas plantas como vocês podem
ver a árvore está completamente comida e
chiquinha folhas e até que eu acho que
só tem aqui porque eles não conseguem
chegar até aqui eu vou ficar aqui
algumas pavimento é mole não é isto
borges tem por onde beirávamos como meu
deus o ciúme é muito bom vamos lá esta
chocolate e estas são um problema de
memória emblema e comer uma folha
acintosa mas nem só quando a comida
mesmo despedindo nbb estamos bem felizes
faz uma prova onde mais uma prova do bbb
não é pretty boy bbb
da série o bob é que o irmão mais velho
que a nova cepa comida boa
mas bom pessoal ou justificar por que
construir espero que vocês tenham
gostado eu não brinquei muito com o bebê
porque eu estava meio assustado então eu
não quis incomodar muito o que é esse
que foi mais um vídeo para explicar e
prever se apresentar este blog porque
certamente vai aparecer em mais vídeos
aqui no canal mexe eu tenho que ter
calma porque ainda é muito bebê e ainda
está muito assustado mas qualquer forma
pessoal já sabem como tem um novo preço
podem ver eu dei o que vocês acham e 130
por ser o dono com provas claras que
este bonde a voz fala comigo no inter
grêmio e nós combinamos que já sabem só
comem também brincadeiras novas para
fazer aqui com os dois bólides porque
agora vão brincar muito e eu possa
aproveitar e fazer alguma coisa imaginem
só construir um parque de diversões
próximas boris vai ser muito menos
comentei isso querem ver isso mas só
para quem está aqui o vídeo já sabem
mexer muito moleque mesmo isso ajuda
muito é que o canal e inscreva se não
forem inscritos e é isso fiquem bem até
a próxima